وفي التطورات الميدانيه افادت اذاعه الجيش
الاسرائيلي بانسحاب الفرقه ال6 من قطاع
غزه مشيره انه بقيت في القطاع ثلاث فرق من
الجيش هي الفرق ال8
وال9
و12 من جهتها قالت صحيفه اسرائيل هيون ان
الجيش قرر تقليص عدد القوات في قطاع غزه
بعد شهرين ونصف من بدء العمليه البريه
واضافت ان الفرقه ال6 لعبت دورا مهما في
القتال بقطاع غزه خلال الاشهر
الاخيره والفرقه
ال6 هي فرقه مدرعه نظاميه تتبع للقياده
الشماليه في الجيش الاسرائيلي وشاركت في
معظم عملياته العسكريه وتضم عده الويه
ابرزها اللواء
188 واللواء السابع ولواء جولاني ولواء
عتسيون اضافه الى كتائب سلاح الهندسه يتبع
للفر فرقه ايضا لواء مدفعيه يتمركز في
الجولان السوري المحتل ومعه قوات دعم
واسناد قتاليه اخرى الفرقه السادسه وال
كانت بدات الهجوم البري على قطاع غزه في
ال 26 من اكتوبر الماضي تركز عملها في
البدايه شمالي القطاع في بيت حنون وبيت
لاغيه ثم في بعض احياء مدينه غزه مثل مخيم
الشاطئ غربا وحي الشجاعيه شرقا لاحقا عملت
الفرقه في وسط القطاع في منطقه جحر وصولا
الى مناطق اخرى في الوسط قبل سحبها اليوم
تحت غطاء ناري
كثيف